thousands of years ago that came a night
that lasted a generation Kings froze to
death in their castles same as the
Shepherd's in marriage and women
smothered their babies rather than see
them starve and wept and felt the tears
freeze on their cheeks so is this the
sort of story that you like in that
darkness the White Walkers came for the
first kind they structures cities and
kingdoms riding their dead horses
hunting with their packs of pale spiders
seven pounds what's up ladies and
gentlemen today I want to talk about a
few things that may take place during
the final season of the Game of Thrones
television series there are a few
passages I want to read to you as well
about the long night and the others that
will add some context to what we may see
for those of you that haven't read any
of the books the long night is how
Westeros refers to a period of time when
the harshest winter in total darkness
fell across the world of planet toasts
it happened around 8,000 years ago
during the Age of Heroes the long night
lasted an entire generation according to
legends in the midst of this darkness
the others emerged from the lands of
always winter the wielded razor thin
swords made completely out of ice and
they raised White's to fight against
humanity this was when the children of
the forest and the first men became
allies to fight against them and as we
know from the television show the
children of the forest actually created
the night king as a weapon to fight
against the first men that were
destroying their lands but there came a
point as far as we know when the others
became out of control so the children
had to then form an alliance with the
people they were once at war with in
order to try and stop them it wasn't
until it was discovered that dragonglass
could kill them that the children of the
forest and the first men actually stood
a chance against them and were able to
beat them back up north the first
members of the Nights Watch drove the
others back during what is known as the
war for the dawn once they were able to
contain them in the north they devised a
plan to keep them there that way
something like this could never happen
again according to legend it was brain
the Builder who raised the wall the
structure made completely out of ice
with the magical spells that were put
into its foundation in order to keep the
others from ever getting south again
then the Nights Watch was formed so that
there were men who could guard the wall
and keep an eye on any of the activity
that was going on up north thousands of
years went by before we ever heard from
the others again but as we know from the
television show in the books they are
back and from all accounts they are out
for blood and heading south one of the
most famous phrases in the story are the
words of House Stark
winter is coming which does have several
different meanings you can look at it
literal as if the weather is about to
change or you can look at it in the more
ominous way meaning the others are
coming and they bring the storm with
them winters in this world are extremely
harsh and can last for many many years
but what I've been wondering is how bad
this winter is going to be according to
some people in this world this winter
can be just as bad as the long night
Melisandre believes that there will be
another long night and considering the
old man refer to this in one of her
tales to bring I think this winter may
be one of if not the worst winter on
record I think most of us do believe
that this winter and what comes with the
winter will end up completely changing
the face of Westeros we may see history
repeat itself once again another
prophecy says that when the others
return azor Ahai will be reborn who will
lead the fight against the others I'm
not going to go into a Zora hide because
the prophecy can fit so many different
people but everything in the story and
show does seem to be lining up for all
of this to happen once again but george
RR martin told us that this story will
have a bittersweet ending so i don't
think we're going to see some missoura
hide defeat the others in battle then
everyone's going to live happily ever
after we're going to feel some severe
loss after this is all said and done not
only do the others already have an
extremely large army but the knight King
can actually raise the dead so as they
are running over towns and villages as
they work their way south the knight
king will more than likely be raising
all those people from the dead to add
more meat for his army creating the
largest army this world has ever seen
the knight king can also raise animals
from the dead we've seen him and some of
the white walkers riding on their dead
horses but what else can we see during
this new war for the dawn owned and told
brand that they were riding their dead
horses and hunting with their packs of
pale white spy
eaters that were bigger towns in the
world of Ice and Fire book on page 11 it
talks about the long night and there's
actually a picture of a giant ice spider
with what looks like to be a white
Walker riding on its back it says there
are other tales
harder to credit and yet more central to
the old histories about creatures known
as the others according to these tales
they came from the frozen lands of
always winter bringing the cold and
darkness with them as they sought to
extinguish all light and warmth the
tales go on to say they wrote monstrous
ice spiders and horses of the Dead
resurrected to serve them just as they
resurrect the dead men to fight on their
behalf I always found that interesting
that this was mentioned again and they
also added some artwork of these ice
spiders if he heard the process George
wind through to make this book I don't
think he would have wasted any of these
pages I do think we are going to see ice
spiders and I was actually talking a
gray area in cows Luke and chickens last
night and I told them I was going to
make this video and I asked them what
they thought about the possibility of us
seeing ice biters and snow bears
fighting in the night Kings army and
they both agreed that we probably would
see them too I remember when the plotly
came out and it mentioned the white
zombie polar bear some people thought
that it may have just been added in
there to sound cool which it could still
be the case but it's not completely made
up because there are snow bears north of
the wall one of the wildlings who is
known as six skins controlled many
different animals and one of those was a
snow bear so any animal that is north of
the wall in this world can potentially
be turned into a white brain stark also
came into contact with a snow bear that
was missing half of its head now I know
we haven't seen them in the show yet but
there are several things north of the
wall that we haven't seen yet but now
that winter is here I expect to see the
night king and his army grow and become
even more deadly and dangerous we may
even see brains direwolf summer come
back as a white dire wolf unless its
body was burned when the cave exploded
by lys little fireball but as far as I
know she only sealed off the tunnel I
don't think it destroyed the entire cave
what do you all think about the
potential the knight king's army has
considering he can raise just about
anything what other types of animals do
you think we can see come back as a
white also what are your thoughts now
that winter is here how harsh do you
think it's going to be will it last an
entire generation like before with Kings
freezing to death in urk
same as the Shepherd's in their huts
will mother smother their babies instead
of seeing them starve I do expect to see
the White Walkers on their dead horses
sweep through cities and kingdoms
slaughtering thousands upon thousands of
people they will get south of the wall
and marched through a significant amount
of Westeros before anyone is able to
slow them down all the work and magic
that went into building the wall to
prevent them from terrorizing this world
once again will be gone
the Nights Watch won't be able to stop
them and just as Jon Snow said all the
southern Kings can't stop them but if
everyone can come together and unite
then at least we can give these [ __ ]
a fight do you remember the story
Alistair thorne told John and Sam about
the time he was north of the wall for
six months he told them they don't know
cold
he said trees that were a hundred foot
tall were ripped out of the ground from
the wind he said if he took her hand out
of your glove to take a piss it would
turn black from the frost he also said
that they had to eat their horses and it
even got so bad that they had to start
eating the dead bodies
that's about as desperate of a situation
you can be in if this does end up being
one of the worst winters in recorded
history a wonder of ports of Westeros
will be driven to this point of cold and
starvation
especially when the night king and his
army gets out of the wall and they bring
the cold with them the show is finally
about to reach its climax that has been
teased and hyped ever since the very
first episode and it's going to get very
interesting but comment below and give
me all your thoughts on this are we
about to see is a long night 2.0 let me
know I also have an announcement to make
for those of you that weren't here last
time I will be making some group videos
when season seven begins we're going to
be doing some live streams with me gray
area cow spook and chickens and secrets
of the Citadel after every new episode
end and I think we will do another live
stream later in the week too that way we
can get predictions for the upcoming
episodes and also take some questions
from the live chat all of us are still
going to be making our own individual
videos on our own channels just like we
have always been doing but twice a week
we will come together as a team and give
you all these bonus live streams so
hopefully you will come hang out with us
and discuss the new episodes but make
sure you subscribe to each channel
because we're going to take turns and
stream on a different channel each week
also check out this tease or that gray
area made for the group thanks for the
support I'll see everyone down in the
comments
by 10,000 skilled soldiers to fight for
the golden company
talking groans Kyle's [ __ ] chicken
gray area secrets of the Citadel
[Music]
contract the golden company the golden
company the golden couple the golden
company the golden company or word is
good as gold
our word is good as gold
our word is gonna go beneath the gold
the bittersteel beneath the gold the
bitter steel and these are gold no pay
the repeal that our word is cool